[Musique]
dimanche 26 février au Salon
International de l'Agriculture Porte de
Versailles à Paris bonjour à tous et
bienvenue au salon et la haut vers ses
portes il y a quelques minutes et
regardez les allées comme on faisait ça
être rempli de visiteurs les exposants
du village réunion ont ravitaillé leur
stand il se tiennent prêt à redémarrer
une journée des plus intenses parmi les
personnalités attendues aujourd'hui la
visite d'Édouard Philippe ancien Premier
ministre
à chaque fois que je viens au salon de
l'agriculture je commence par le stand
de les stands des Outre-mer je le fais
parce que c'est devenu une habitude
parce que j'aime ça parce que cette
probablement parmi les stands les plus
sympathiques du salon et parce que dire
et redire que les outre-mer sont
évidemment une richesse de la France et
que leur agriculture est une richesse de
ces territoires me parlait un message
voilà donc c'est à la fois important de
le dire et je vais vous dire en plus
c'est agréable
c'est l'une des nouveautés de ce salon
la marque 100% à la Réunion qui assure
la traçabilité et l'excellence du
savoir-faire de notre département rappel
de comment ça marche avec Sophie rouge
une marque différente gage de qualité et
de traçabilité sur l'origine de la
Réunion
Eric Laval spécialisée en produits rares
tels que le sirop de galabé ou les
épices l'arborent fièrement sur son
stand et ses produits je travaille avec
quelques chefs
sur Paris ou même sur sur l'étranger
Belgique ou la Suisse donc ça ça leur
certifie vraiment que le produit vit qui
soit du curcuma ou la vanille ou autre
c'est certifié 100% des produits
d'origine réunion une marque qui se
décline également soulignant l'origine
100% bio et où l'excellence du
territoire réunionnais Bernard Savreux a
reçu la mention excellence pas si facile
à obtenir
la médaille d'or en 2022
il vient d'avoir la médaille d'argent en
2023 au mois de février au Concours des
villes de France et il est au concours
pour mardi prochain pour le miel c'est
100% la réunion dans la mesure où il est
produit et il est récolté à la Réunion
donc là-dessus il y a aucune faille
possible on aimerait que le plus grand
nombre des producteurs le plus grand
nombre des transformateurs puissent
s'inscrire dans cette démarche et porter
le label 100% la Réunion parce que c'est
aussi pour nous une façon de mettre en
avant l'agriculture locale à ce jour 42
demandes d'adhésion à la marque ont été
formulés pour 200 produits
toutes les infos sont à retrouver sur le
site
certains produits sont déjà connus ici
en métropole et donne viennent prendre
leur marque à l'image de ses petits pots
pour bébé de Mamie la fée va y aller
bonjour bonjour c'est une première
participation pour vous ce salon comment
ce que ça se passe très bien on est très
content de notre première journée déjà
c'est une très belle opportunité d'être
ici que le
départ et c'est une très belle journée
les gens sont très curieux de en tout
cas ceux qui connaissent pas encore les
saveurs de la Réunion
de course ceux qui vivent ici les
Réunionnais d'ici sont très content
de retrouver leur saveur alors une
marque 100% la Réunion c'est à dire
alors en fait c'est à dire qu'on ne
transforme que des produits issus de
l'agriculture
naissent et encore plus nous on a poussé
plus loin c'est ici de la culture
biologique réunionnaise 100% bio et
c'est pour ça qu'on a obtenu aussi la
marque 100% la Réunion bio qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de ce salon alors en fait
déjà de la visibilité et puis vraiment
pouvoir faire découvrir ces nouvelles
saveurs un maximum de personnes et de
bébé en particulier parce que c'est une
un nouveau produit et une nouvelle offre
qui change de ce qu'on peut trouver sur
le marché on est nous en fait sur des
produits 100% locaux et 100% fruit ou
légumes sans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un dimanche au salon regardez les allées
comment serait rapidement à se remplir
les visiteurs viennent en famille entre
amis ils se montrent plutôt agréablement
surpris intéressé par les produits et
par l'idée de venir à La Réunion
quelques réactions
on espère bientôt y aller et c'est un
plaisir ça sera un plaisir d'aller
découvrir sur place le rhum voilà et
puis toutes les autres spécialités
Lille on a fait le tour là pendant
pendant l'été ici ça nous rappelle un
petit peu les vacances ça nous rappelle
un peu les vacances ça donnerait
de la passion en général tout petit et
sans goût du coup sur mes fruits
préférés donc ça me fait plaisir
le mag au coeur de salon international
de l'agriculture c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dès demain
[Musique]